the margin between the Pacific plate and  the North American plate is expressed in  California by a complex assemblage of  faults the San Andreas Fault  accommodates most of the relative  displacement between these two plates  generating seismic activity in the park  field segment this results in magnitude  6 earthquakes that repeat in average  every 20 years this animation shows a  dynamic simulation of the earthquake  cycle at park field which bears some  resemblance to the 1956 and the 2004  events the color intensity is related to  the velocity of slippage between the two  plates the history of slip includes  seismic ruptures for shocks and  aftershocks fault creep and episodic  slow slip events the model spontaneously  reproduces the location of the  nucleation of the latest to magnitude 6  earthquakes such simulations could in  principle be used to assess the full  range of earthquake patterns that a  particular fault system might produce  you